okay looking good so far what we got
here you are also here that is wonderful
I am glad to see that you are also here
ah there it is
I'm still jury-rigging this off my phone
actually when I did a live strain on my
other channel a little while ago and I
got the webcam working I realized how
much worse the video quality is on the
webcam than my phone so I'm just gonna
keep doing it this way alright so hope
everyone is doing okay am i coming
through clear hey Kara hi hi this I
don't have like anything you know cute
planned this time like I did last time
with the with the food or whatever else
because this has been just uh a week or
so I know it's weird to say on a Tuesday
but like the week that's passed since I
last hit one of these so yeah my ability
to like prep and prepare anything clever
or funny is is limited do the Joker lap
which one I gave you ten options come on
come at me with more than that
I empathize with the feeling of oh just
finish eating my leftover pasta and I
feel I came back the 88 pounds I lost
pasta does that to you it really does oh
yeah I love pasta but yeah man it just
kind of sits there sometimes missed a
couple of these good to be back well
it's good to have you back heading for
the wine yeah
is it water mmm-hmm
still doing better than me I've spent
months planning all the things I want to
do with my 27 projects see the thing is
you're assuming I don't also do that on
top of the stuff that I actually get
done not sure I Madeline 27 but I've got
a lot like some of which is kind of my
responsibility some of which I brought
on to myself so I get to make the life
shoes from near the beginning for a
change well it's nice to have you how
often do you watch films and television
shows purely for entertainment anymore
almost never ha ha
like I I suppose most recently I we
could count Umbrella Academy cuz I never
did end up making a video about that but
even want to watch that I'd like debated
will I should I ultimately I decided not
to but like it's really rare that I
watch something knowing that I'm not
gonna get any content out of it that
does not happen very often at all
anymore thankfully I really enjoy most
the stuff I watch degree content about
and stuff I'd be watching anyway so like
that helps but yeah watching stuff for
pleasure and nothing else not not
something I do very much anymore in the
meantime I've been watching the Josh
Kirby time warriors series god awfully
wonderful I'm not familiar with that so
I'm kind of raising an eyebrow what's
your view on the x-men not joining the
MCU for a very long time according to
Kevin Feige well he's been saying since
the merger was first announced that they
are moving forward with their existing
plans and they are not making any plans
for x-men until the act until the
acquisition finished like he's been
saying that the whole time so the fact
that it's like I saw it as a news
headline like x-men
coming to MCU for a while and I look at
it and it's basically Kevin Feige saying
the same thing he's been saying for like
a year and a half and I'm like how was
that news why did everyone think he was
lying
I mean look okay I'll grant there are a
lot of people in entertainment positions
who talk to the press who do flat-out
lie but just look at his track record
Kevin Feige is not JJ Abrams alright
he's not known for flat-out lying to the
fan base for the sake of a surprise like
I think if he had stuff you would have
said and I'd so like nothing about that
was surprising to me and it's weird to
me that people seem surprised
starting on classic who have watched
earth shock wargames Genesis to the dogs
so far any suggestions don't want to
watch next I mean my suggestion will
always be city of death because it's the
best send you the trailer on Twitter DM
when the stream is over cool I will
check that out let's see he's indicated
that nothing x-men is going to be
happening for at least 5 years which
makes sense I mean you need to realize
part of the reason Marvel has two to
three movies coming out every year is
because they've got these things in
continual development these things don't
have a super quick turnaround time they
are like from concept to finish film
yeah
it's about five years the sequels turn
around slightly faster because you've
got a lot of groundwork laid but first
films yeah yeah that tracks that makes
sense
um I mean honestly it's probably in
Marvel's best interest to wait that long
anyways because like this will give them
a good you know four to five years to
work on whatever the MCU and the
Avengers looks like after endgame and so
it doesn't look like they're immediately
just throwing in the x-men there and
they'll actually have it in their back
pocket so if things like oh people
aren't totally buying our Avengers
lineup that's - cap and Tony and Thor so
oh what can we do oh we can give them
Wolverine so you know not that I'm
saying I don't think that's a decision
being made for that cynical purpose but
I'm saying like icing you know that's
silver lining for them have you ever
watched Rick and Morty I did three
episodes and real
I do not like watching these people lie
I get why it's popular and it's super
clever and its really well-thought-out
but like I just don't enjoy spending
time with those characters like at all
what a wonderful YouTube breeze oh hi
blend
oh I love me a good Douglas Adams quote
I thought some new Adams family trailer
yes I did see that okay so there is a
new Addams Family movie coming out if
you didn't already know
it's animated and it's stylized to more
closely resembled the original cartoon
not like TV show cartoons like newspaper
cartoons that the Addams family
originated as now watching the trailer
it's taking me a little while to get
used to the look it's super stylized
which in general I'm in favor of but I'm
just not used to it over the course of
the two minutes however long the thing
is um so I'm still getting used to it I
think this was a really good way to move
forward though because I don't think you
can do live-action Addams Family any
better than we already got so I think
going animated and bringing back to its
visual roots is probably the best way to
go it's got potential I hope it's good I
like it didn't fire me up but I'm like
okay like I want this to work
I like Addams Family Norwegian ravenclaw
hufflepuff from Texas I love that that's
become a thing with like just sort of
announcing your your Hogwarts house and
where you're from I like that that's a
thing here now more Ravenclaw's I'm
hyped because Bette Midler is voicing
grandma ma I love Bette Midler oh that's
who she was voiced like I saw the cast
list at the end of the trailer but I
didn't bother to look up who they were
gonna be like I should have looked duh
but no that's no that's cool I get
behind by casting um do you have any
obviously low-budget shows or movies you
enjoy um uh not really and by that I
mean like the tone of your question
makes me think like things that you can
look at until oh god they had no money
I'm not real
I do have a very high appreciation for
things that were made for very little
money but look like something that was
shot for more money so I don't I'm not
really a big fan of things where you can
see how cheap it was that's just it's
not really my bag you know it kind of
goes in the same thing I've never bought
into the whole so bad it's good thing
it's just not me
Irish hufflepuffs Oregonian Ravenclaw's
England Gryffindor oh there are some
Gryffindor's who turn up here
Slytherin from Romania yeah very cool
as far as movies go did DC are Marvel do
a better Captain Marvel okay I can't
answer that cuz I still haven't seen
shoes am yet like hopefully if I have
not completely buggered up my scheduling
I will get to see Shazam on Thursday
maybe Friday oh it'll be Friday Friday
night I'll finally get to see Shazam and
I look I may not do a review because at
this was like it's been a week since it
came out so unless I unless it makes me
really want to talk about it which
sometimes happens I'm not gonna promise
a review of that one Swedish hufflepuff
hufflepuff and a Oh a puck wedgie ha ha
ha Wampus from London hufflepuff from
Cornwall lots of hufflepuffs love it
Scottish Slytherin or slither buff
pricks like hugs nice
yeah the puffs whoa squad Slytherin from
America yeah like I I was not too lonely
for the persons that they were from
Gryffindor cuz it cuz I do feel like
that's probably the least represented
house in the in the circle of people who
follow me on a regular basis Oh see if
you can it is worth it for me it was
just such a good time and you don't have
to do a review and could just manage any
I'm one of the livestreams I mean which
I probably will like if I get this Trans
Am I'm sure I won't mention it
in the livestream Slytherin and
Thunderbird cool have you ever have you
ever anything created by Jerry Anderson
Oh like the Captain Scarlet Thunderbirds
stuff
no like I I know who he is I know what
he did um but no I've never really
watched any of that stuff I'm seeing
like clips here or there
have you seen glass I were you the one
who is asking this last time because I
have a review up for glass like go for
something that's not new like check the
check my video stream check the feed I
reviewed that movie also a Scottish
Slytherin who big Slytherin banner on my
bedroom wall my southern banner is up in
my cubicle at work a Marylander do you
have a favorite robot Oh huh I mean I'm
I'm really partial to bb-8 and I know
this kind of blasphemy like if for that
kind of drawing I'm supposed to like r2
but it's just something by the way bb-8
rolls around I really do like him a lot
aside from him
ooh baymax baymax would be right up
there oh he might even you know yeah i
think i think baymax is gonna take it
from big hero 6 nothing against
Gryffindor's yes
yes absolutely
okay yeah now I'm getting have you seen
glass from other people now you people
are just messing with me I'm gonna add
have you seen glass to the to the
drinking game list I'm human I hate
labels fair enough
have you seen continuum no like that
that sounds vaguely familiar I feel like
I've heard that before but I definitely
haven't seen it I'm not
even sure I can remember what it is I
mean my brain goes to sci-fi miss but I
don't know we got here
do you have you read Dracula
I did I did long time ago I think God I
think it was in high school when I read
Dracula wasn't even assigned it just
read it um I used to read a lot more but
ya know I've uh III haven't even read
Dracula
it's really interesting because there's
so few things as long as that is written
in the narrative that is because if
you've never read Dracula and like you
only know the movies it's written as a
collection of letters diary and log
entries so it's like across it's
effectively got various narrators with
like little glimpses of what it is
that's going on it's actually a pretty
interesting way to go about it
have you seen glassware do you prefer
pronouns what type of music do you
listen to and that's the drinking game
trifecta right there ah just like I'm
trying to order if people asking for my
name should be added to that list I just
have to assume at this point that not
very many people watch the end credits
which I suppose fair enough but like my
name is at the end of literally every
video I make so are you trying to get it
drunk half a scene glass oh god you guys
you guys are memeing it up on me already
did you ever see Kwan did you ever watch
quantum leap I remember seeing one
episode when I was like 5 I don't really
remember what it was about I remember
and I remember it ended it had an end
gag of him like leaping into the body of
a woman so he was on a bus in a dress
but like I don't I haven't seen it aside
from that and
don't I hate to be a jerk about I don't
really want to because I know the ending
is terrible and like things that don't
stick the ending bother me anyways
so the glass of the daleks Howie
have you seen it's too bad fools video
I'm brick see yes I have um so anyway
anyone who doesn't subscribe to Stu
bagful first of all you should his
stuffs awesome his latest video that he
that he put out was talking about Briggs
in but it was presented as if Briggs it
were a TV show that he was trying to to
do a review on he's like this is the
most confounding thing since lost after
season 3 it's it was an it was an
entertaining way for him to channel his
frustration about what's been going on
let's see Kindle e-books or actual paper
books I very much prefer paper books
still at this point but that has more
than a bit to do with the fact that I
don't have a Kindle I don't have an
e-book reader so if I get an e-book I
have to read it on my phone which you
know not a favorite my opinion might
vary like if I actually had a proper
e-book reader but so far I don't so
paper very much um and also I have my
general hesitancy with non-physical
media like I I I made the move with with
music but like I still really don't like
non-physical media when it comes to
movies video games you know I just I I
like knowing that it's that I can put it
in my hand it's a fiscal thing I own
instead of a digital thing that I'm
leasing what what do you think of Donald
Trump being cast in and um I like I
don't know what angled even come at that
statement from who's your YouTube
archrival I'm
oh I don't have one I've got a
podcasting our tribal that's the
original shag I don't think if I have a
YouTube archrival then it's a war that
they're waging on their own Kazaam are
you going to see endgame of course I'm
gonna see any game collusion of the
Daleks oh love how old books smell like
I love the smell of a bookstore actually
I went I went down to the Brattleboro
and I met with a friend for for lunch
and we just wandered around I actually
hadn't wandered around Brattleboro
before and we went to this bookstore I
was just like oh man I haven't been in a
like a nice small bookstore no I'm Joe I
just stepped it Amelie Oh books oh
that's nice
wait irredeemable shag yes if you're the
irredeemable shag is one of the more
prevalent voices on the fired water
podcasting network which is where tough
like a girl airs pronouns and names of
the Daleks
any thoughts on contra points she's
really good at what she does like
preposterous ly good every now and then
not really with the recent stuff but
like stuff from a year ago was a little
too um sort of sketch like for me like a
little bit too much into characters and
she's moved a little bit away from that
at this point and and seems to have more
of a focus on getting her point across
and using characters as it fits that
whereas there are some of the ones from
like a year year and a half ago where it
felt like the priority was the carry
that she was over prioritizing the
characters but what she does is amazing
she does amazing work
do you like Oreos I mean oh I'll eat an
Oreo
I've net I'd like I can't remember I
don't remember the last time like I
bought Oreos for myself so like I don't
like them enough to do that
so 10 take that as you will so yeah that
this is gonna be a fair amount of me
just reacting to this cuz like I said I
don't really have a I don't have a plant
aiya I'm too beat up by this week or
actually the last month or so in a lot
of ways to have much going on oh oh you
know what I did have a couple other
things that I received that I want to
let people know about that I've kept
forgetting to mention um I got somebody
sent me an Amazon gift card which was
very cool um they also sent a card with
it they said I could read on air don't
know where I put it cuz I still haven't
figured out a filing system for the
stuff you people send me but um thank
you for that if you're watching and in
addition to that I was sent creature
comforts season one actually watch this
with with my daughter
this past weekend and she got a kick out
of this um quite a bit she is she really
she really did enjoy some of those quite
a quite a lot and I've got Cruikshank's
yeah guys ugly I love him I love how
ugly he is haha
ah so this was nice to get and I'll
mention it before if there's if anyone
sent me something that I haven't
mentioned in a livestream or otherwise
reached out to you to let you know I got
um feel free to contact me like by
direct message or email or Twitter or
whatever just to check because I have
tried to mention everything that I've
got that I got you know that was meant
to come to me for my birthday
but I may still have missed up because I
am NOT as organized as you'd think I
should be or as I think I should be but
there you go
Kirk shank in the Daleks yeah
did you watch WrestleMania I have a
watch professor professional wrestling
since I was since
the 80s there's gonna be a prequel to
grease citation needed because I don't
want that to be true which would you
want to be Time Lord or Jedi um I don't
know because they both have a lot of
really restrictive BS rules I like I
don't know like good because I know with
Jedi the force power that I would abuse
the most is apparently totally cool for
lightside Jedi's to use which is the
Jedi mind trick
I would spam the heck out of that
apparently it's cool to override for you
well that your your car matically
balanced doing that but at the same time
like the whole you know you can't know
love and you can't like bite me but then
you know the time lords well depending
on what you considered we can in the way
that Time Lords even reproduce is just
stupid and then they've got all their
rules and it seems like the doctor like
he he gets to you know bend the rules
but it really does seem like it's like
him and the master on the rani like only
a handful of them you get exiled and
still have access to the cool stuff like
TARDIS's or whatnot so like I don't know
assuming that I wouldn't be a rogue of
either one yes Time Lords but like I
yeah I think I think either one like to
be in the group proper and doing it the
way they would want me to do it I
honestly think either one would suck
Sith Lord of the Daleks I'm sure I'm
sure
I'm sorry I've gotta go quiet just cuz
I'm trying to figure out where things
aren't here I would just sit and use
telekinesis for everything well yeah
there be that too oh there's another one
we can add to the drinking game list do
you have any pets that one does get
asked up fairly regularly I do not
because I do not have the time to take
care of any my daughter has a ham
like I'm I'm mildly allergic to cats
it's not like severe it's not like I
can't be in a house that has cats but
like I could never let it if I had a cat
I could never let it in my room because
they can't have the cat hair like where
I sleep and I'm more of a dog person
anyway but like I travel a lot like
every other weekend I'm just flat-out
not here and that's not fair to a dog so
yeah
their pets are not in my life or in my
future anytime soon you look so good has
a sit though haha actually I might be
bringing back the thus if looking over
less number in a in about a month we'll
see I'm waiting to find out on that
drinking game of the Daleks yeah is it
bad I just like the fifth doctor no cuz
I actually think at this point he is my
least favorite doctor that's if that's
if I'm going beyond the the TV show
because then I get to incorporate Big
Finish and that brings six up quite a
bit if I limit it to the TV show fire
still comes then above six but I don't I
really I can't connect with five I don't
get him I don't know if you could have a
dog what breed would you want um I mean
something small like something that
isn't high energy like I want a lap dog
basically so you know I don't know Corgi
I've had dachshunds before I've had a
bulldog so things along those lines
is it bad that the twelfth doctor is my
favorite know what it's not bad that any
doctor is your favorite whoever your
favorite doctor is it's right for you of
course it's not bad
do you watch Game of Thrones I do I'll
be doing episode by episode reviews when
that starts up again yeah or at least
I'll try to the last couple things aside
from Doctor Who that I've done episode
by episode arm I've dropped off either
because it was hard for me to keep up
with them or like nobody was watching
and while I tried very hard not to have
chasing views be a
be part of what dictates what I do if I
see like geez nobody's like that that to
me says my audience doesn't care maybe I
could provide them with something that
they do care about a little bit more
than that ten was overrated yes I do
agree with that that's probably one of
my more controversial Doctor Who stances
what's your favorite Ben and Jerry's
current or of all time because my
favorite is actually a retired flavor so
I could go either way with that one
is there a vehicle you always wanted not
really I'm not a I'm not a car person
and I don't care about boats motorcycles
scare me so uh no no I mean not a real
vehicle fantastical unsure but I'll take
a TARDIS but like real vehicles no no
not not so much is of the Daleks a
drinking game now Oh God if that ever if
that was ever like part of the drinking
game we'd all be dead by the heat by the
end of any given live stream uh ten is
my least favorite doctor ever ooh I'm
not quite at that point but like that's
bold who's your favorite superhero
spider-man
what about planes I'm not I don't have
any interest in owning a plane I don't
know how to fly and I wouldn't trust
myself even if I learned how to do it
any co.labs coming up yes um
is it oh I gotta edit that Sunday I have
a collaboration video coming up on
Sunday spider-man here to alcohol point
anything of the daleks any ben and
jerry's up here in canada we only get
four or five flavors oh god April I am
so sorry my favorite that is still
current is triple caramel chunk my
favorite retired flavor was Vermont II
Python that was great
who is your favorite fictional character
I I don't have an answer to that that's
that's that's too broad I mean like
there's a reason when I when I do list
some stuff I usually have a pretty
narrowly defined criteria that I'm going
with fish food fish food is good I'm not
huge on chocolate ice cream though like
Jade chocolate can be a very
overpowering flavor for me so while I do
like fish food it's a little too
chocolate for my taste
Ben eater is used to have give me s'more
which was great
most of theirs are great their main
chocolate cookies also really good is
the by rap video this month or has that
been delayed yes it it has been delayed
I am sorry to keep delaying of the thing
is I really want to do that one with Liz
and I'm I have a number of videos that I
want to do with her I want to pick up
and do more of the sorting MCU
characters into Hogwarts houses and I
want to do that with her when Gotham
ends we're gonna do top ten Gotham
characters when I you know after after
the show's over but I am trying to
prioritize the the bisexual
representation video in terms of
prioritizing what Records I'm doing with
her but it it's just a matter of
scheduling I am sorry for that
I have already shot this month's lgbtq+
video which was one that I hadn't been
initially thinking of but it's again
it's one of those things that it's like
I saw something I looked into it I was
like oh I'm talking about that um not to
say that it's like a specific thing that
happened but just like a thing that I
dug into that I hadn't bothered digging
into before and I'm like wait a minute
hmm so that'll be next week next week
Friday I think
tell us about the collab it's just a few
days away you can wait have you sorted
Doctor Who characters into Hogwarts no
that's on my to-do list that one I'll do
on my own because why I have gotten Liz
into Doctor Who she's not that far along
with it it's something she only watches
with me on occasion I'm we're going
through a very heavily curated viewing
I'm skipping a lot of stuff by and pans
representation I hope what like the
problem is at least as far as media goes
the media representation doesn't really
distinguish pansexual very often so I I
think trying to do something like
pansexual representation is really hard
because while there are certainly a fair
number of characters who you could
interpret or headcanon as pansexual by
and large bisexual is about as close as
you're gonna get and honestly even
that's kind of scant so like if we talk
about pansexual well at all it'll
probably get rolled into the bisexual
discussion do you think Game of Thrones
is overrated um I don't know because
like the years when it's been like the
thing I think it's usually been pretty
good um you know some seasons have not
been there are specific seasons and
specific episodes that I definitely
think are overrated or underrated but
the show overall no I think the show is
really good by and large
boy there's a there's a slip of the
tongue that happens sometimes like if it
happens every now and then that that
someone will like quote something that I
said in a video be like oh that's clever
and I look and I go oh crap I didn't
even do that on purpose okay cool I'll
take credit anyways and I'm just giving
you the people I'm the curtain
she's gone uh sounds fair enough
what does a good new or long sci-fi book
I don't know cuz I haven't read a sci-fi
book published more recently than I
don't know probably the early 2000s I
don't read much anymore
oh okay there's some interesting
questions going on that I am going to
avoid I think because I don't know what
they're being asked and I don't know I
don't know what you're playing at no
okay Liam I don't know if you're joking
I don't know if you're serious if you're
serious then you haven't been paying
attention to me
and what I talk about and the angle that
I comment things from and if you're
joking it's not funny
so I'm trying to be cool calm and
collected but like I don't know I don't
know how to deal with you right now okay
um we're or the worlds is a good sci-fi
book I never read the book um I've seen
I think the only version of War of the
Worlds I've seen all the way through was
was the Tom Cruise one that Steven
Spielberg did um I mean I know the story
certainly been influential on enough
things that that I I know I know a bit
about but I've never actually read the
original I think that's um that's
actually true of a lot of class except
there's plenty classes stuff that like I
need I feel like I've read it but I
never have um do you enjoy Quentin
Tarantino's movies yes I do although I
almost never feel the need to see them a
second time after I've seen them once
so yeah I uh I I do enjoy his movies I
look forward to seeing them some of them
I like better than others but he's in
sort of the category of directors that I
feel like everything he puts out is
worth seeing at least once in my case as
I said I think well no okay Kill Bill
Vol 1 that's the only one I've seen more
than once but ya know I like his stuff
I'm not gonna ask who the collab is we
just give me a ballpark is it a hoot
uber yes I I will give you that I live
in the same town as HG Wells oh wow tell
them hi from me hey guys good to see you
oh hey channel pump very cool and uh
kind of toast to you sir I enjoy what
you do Oh
spoilers Bailey come on huh your
hairlines doing the wave I remember
getting really freaked out when this
receded initially back in my mid late
20s that I got worried about that but
then it stopped and I'm like that's fine
TARDIS or vortex manipulator Oh TARDIS
vortex manipulator move through time
favorite horror book movie series oh I
don't know because my relationship with
horror is a little odd because I there's
a lot of there's a lot of horror
elements that I really enjoy like I love
monsters I love the gothic vibe of
things but most horror stories and the
tropes of the narratives I just don't
like and I think a lot of them depend on
either having a visceral positive
reaction to you know it's a things like
gore and and and jump scares and whatnot
or they rely on surprise but because so
many horror stories are so tropi they
tend a lot of them tend to reuse that
what is structurally the same twist over
and over and over and over again and I
get bored with a lot of horror stories
which doesn't mean every now and then
when one when one comes out that's like
okay I haven't seen that before
like makes me very happy
gotta go bye oh okay well I don't see
you then how old I am 37
have you seen altered carbon you know um
Tracy I started the first episode I
don't remember why I didn't finish it
guys I didn't like make a decision to
turn it off um I think I'd like
something came up or like I know
something I had to deal with or I don't
know
I cannot remember this was a while ago a
little bit back so like it's yeah I was
gonna say it's in my Netflix queue but
like that's meaningless those five
million forget other things but no I
haven't it actually it kind of fell off
my radar still my Netflix queue but I
never fell off my radar looking great
for 3700 well thank you uh still feeling
pretty good I haven't started falling
apart yet which is which I appreciate
any Buffy videos coming out soon not
really and actually you can blame
yourself for that TV and sin because I
started watching passion of the nerdy
I'm watching that going I can't talk
about any of this better than he already
is so uh yeah I'll just leave them to it
you look about 25 Oh bless you you liar
favorite Harry Potter movie movie I
think I think actually might be
half-blood Prince for movie not the same
as my favorite Harry Potter book cuz
they don't link up I think you're really
handsome man yeah oh thank you
have you seen any movies that were
banned in your country well no because
US doesn't really ban movies not not
like on a on a national level
there are movies that have never come
out over here but that's because no
distributor that's in the stage wants to
release them
we don't there isn't a government
censorship board that prevents movies
from coming in in the u.s. so banned
movie again on a national level don't
really exist
you get bannings on local levels like
towns might decide we're not gonna let
this movie play in a local theater or
you know banned books are a big thing
but that's on a case by case basis with
like school districts and libraries and
what-have-you like on the big national
scale stuff doesn't really get banned
here see who would win in a game of
chess Sherlock or the doctor huh I think
it depends which doctor
I think Sherlock would take it more
often than not though
do you like JK Rowling um
I am frustrated with JK Rowling and I
will leave it at that
do you like house m.d. I did I loved
house it went on I'd say a season too
long um and I'm still mad at them for
using the wrong song to end the last
episode on I'm still mad at them for
that um but I did like I did like house
quite a lot and actually I'm a huge fan
of season four I really loved the format
they went with that that year seven
would win at a chess match yes I think
7th doctor yeah 7th doctor would do you
have a best worst movie from your
childhood I'm not even sure what your
criteria is like movies that from my
childhood that I've revisit like that
still really holds up or that's crap
like I'm not done I'm not entirely sure
what to make of that question what is
your favorite Sherlock version ooh okay
if we're talking specifically just
Sherlock himself
um Basil Rathbone but that doesn't
necessarily mean that his were the best
movies cuz the thing with so many
sherlock iterations cuz there are a ton
it's really rare to find one that nails
every element you'll get ones that have
a really good Sherlock but a crap Watson
I've actually even seen ones like that's
a great wapts and an only an okay
Sherlock I've seen somewhere like they
get the Sherlock Watson dynamic great
but then the story that they're telling
in the mystery isn't that good so it
really can go all over the place
Jeremy Brett is my favorite that's you
know yeah you're talking Sherlock that's
that is a name that should be on your
short list if not your pick
so absolutely what's your daughter's
hamster called our hamsters named buddy
have you seen Lucifer I watched three
episodes of Lucifer and decided not for
me have you seen elementary that one I
think I got six episodes into it was
unfortunately at least in that first
season maybe he got better later I don't
know it was a little too mired in the
the American police procedural format to
the point that like I was guessing who
the killers were in things not because
of like they tip their hand too soon but
just because I know that formula too
well so David Burke David Brooke is the
best Watson I am actually going to
politely disagree James Mason is the
best Watson ever seen blue bloods I did
not do you are supernatural I don't I do
however have a burlesque friend who I
think is still in active warning from
the news that supernatural is coming to
an end
she she's really broken up about that
what is your favorite Gene Wilder film I
mean it's I God see I think the best
film that I've seen him in is Young
Frankenstein my favorite performance
from him is Willy Wonka the Chocolate
Factory though so that's the thing like
my brains
separates this stuff out it separates
the like best movie versus best
performance for this versus that
enlightens I can't stop my brain from
doing this I subdivide if you could
write for any show or movie which show
or movie so ok terms of movies I'm
assuming you mean like franchises oh boy
um I I don't really know because I like
for all the things that my brain does I
don't have a fan fiction brain and I
don't have a brain that like says oh
this would be the best thing to do like
when I'm looking at a story that's
already happened my brain can pick apart
ok it would have been better if they did
this but like coming up from scratch in
an existing world with existing
characters franchises I have a hard time
getting my getting my brain to go that
direction
have you watched the Prisoner I have man
that's a weird show favorite color a
forest green let's see
best movie starring Johnny Depp pre
Pirates of the Caribbean Oh probably
Edward Scissorhands
I guess Hilda has now been nominated for
a Peabody cool I dig that season 1 of
Fargo is great yo God yeah Fargo is
amazing I still need to watch season 3
like again because I don't have the time
to watch things that are not gonna get a
video out of I'm not gonna do a video on
Fargo season 3 it was like a year ago
now so it's really hard for me to find
the time to watch it man this is my life
I'm not complaining I'd like I love well
I love this part of what I do other
things I'm working on but like this I
love this
have you seen the 100 you've asked that
before no I have it have you seen do you
want to see the Russian take on homes I
was not aware that that was a thing that
existed you really need to watch
Discovery another thing that I would
like to see but haven't I gotten to
which Fargo season was your favorite one
or two I likes first season of Fargo go
a little bit better I'm not sure that it
actually is substa it just caught me way
more off-guard whereas the second season
I do think honestly is about as good but
you know it wasn't gonna surprise me as
much have you seen stranger things first
season stranger things is awesome except
for barb no justice for Barb's season to
do stranger things not so much I'm
honestly really nervous for the third
season I'm not excited I'm just nervous
what do you think about penguin and
Riddler shipping I actually for someone
who isn't a shipper I don't begrudge
that one because I love those two
together in Gotham like the two of them
on screen is just wonderful and awesome
and fun and amazing I don't personally
ship them romantically but if somebody
wants to like cool cuz like I want more
of them together anyway so I'm okay with
that
best Gotham villain easily Joker it
depends on who you're gonna give the
mantle of Joker to are you giving it to
Jeremiah or Jerome because I do not see
the two of them on an even plane not by
a heavy margin do you ship John Locke
not really again I'm not really a
shipper by nature did you just say that
any word you can't say that he's joke
man I'm so sorry so sorry Channel pub
yes no that that is joke man see that's
the thing generally I refer to them as
either Jerome or Jeremiah you have coin
joke man which you
very apt what whoa what the heck just
went on here hold up hold up
oh for God's sake all right hang on a
second
I got a there we go let's yeah that's
just
sorry I got chat cleanup to do here and
there we go
cool do you ship boats no I don't mind
being on a boat every now and then um
but like I don't have I don't have like
I don't hear the call of the sea that's
that's not in my blood uh oh sorry I
gotta take this off my head my head's
actually starting to get OH
forgive me I'd like I need to wash my
hair but mmm did we get a troll I see I
don't know and I don't know if that was
trolling or if he was serious but in my
book it doesn't matter with that kind of
behavior I'm gonna bounce you regardless
for me the opening three episodes of
Gotham season 2 were the best opening
television I've ever seen what would you
say is your favorite opener for of a
season of any show honestly I think loss
had an amazing first season um just the
entire opening thing as far as like
narrowing it down to just opening
episodes I it's hard to say because a
lot of the things that I might consider
like my brain has sort of bled episodes
together so I'm not sure where the I
would put the cutoff for opening for a
lot of the stuff like this so like
that's the kind of thing I'd have to
have to sit down and ponder on a bit
more did Liam get booted no I did not
boot Liam we had we had somebody else
who was causing a bit of a ruckus
do you like twin peaks' I've never seen
Twin Peaks like David Lynch is not
really my bag he's not my kind of weird
I like weird but like he's he's on a
different wavelength to me will you
watch any accused episodes besides the
Sean Bean one um I don't know I mean
like it was a good show and I'd be up
for it in theory but I mean as has come
up in the chat I don't really have time
these days for anything that I'm not
also getting a video out of so it's it's
really hard to to just find the time for
that kind of stuff
what is your pronoun whatever makes
sense in your head also take a drink
favorite Lovecraft story I honestly I
cannot remember uh I've read a handful
of Lovecraft stories
oddly enough none of the Cthulhu linked
ones um but there was one that he wrote
that I cannot remember the name of that
was from the perspective of somebody
clawing their way out of this sort of
locked off area and then sort of what
happens from there and I get like I know
I don't want to talk more about it cuz
it I mean it was a good name it cuz I
really liked it but it was uh it was
good and he also had one again I cannot
remember the name of it he had one those
about the kind of like the color
spectrum and the like there was a
monster that you couldn't see because it
was a color that the human eye didn't
pick up that was a good one too
[Music]
I see you own cards against humanity'
any other games you play um I I game
every now and then I used to have a
gaming group but it kind of the Paul who
used to be on the channel every now and
then and used to host the game regroups
he had he had a second kid so I don't
really do that anymore a favorite
Stephen King story ooh boy um this is
where this is that point where I get to
confess to never having finished reading
a Stephen King story I've tried a few
things but um I don't know his writing
style it doesn't grab me I'm not sure
what it is the color in space oh good
call thank you
what are you drinking um water did you
know the human eye can see more shades
of green than any other color oh I did
not very interesting
I read Carrie when it was new
not much besides that favorite James
Cameron movie aliens what superheroes
for Kit Harington play Captain Britain
do you read a lot no I don't have time
like I do not read very much I'm in the
middle of reading now because I got a
patron commissioned me to read a book so
this is like the first book I'll have
red covered cover in three years at
least so yeah do you think Marvel will
be brave enough to give us openly gay
character in the Eternals
um see what yes I do hope that they do
that I haven't been following the
Eternals thing very much I've seen that
rumbling that you know maybe they're
gonna do a gay character I haven't like
dug into those stories very much and the
reason I mentioned that is because my
way
I have an issue is going to be is Marvel
itself actually saying that they are
going to have a gay character in that
film or is that the rumor mill that is
circulating because if I can't track it
back to a source then I'm not gonna hold
Marvel accountable for that regardless I
would like to see it happen
but I wouldn't consider it like
quote-unquote pulling a rolling unless
they had said they were going to and
then failed to deliver will there be a
drunk angry Phoenix review possibly well
I I don't I don't do drinking videos as
a rule but like I've got one you go back
find my Inhumans thing that was that I
got I got happy because I had to to get
through that but yeah Dark Phoenix if
it's as bad as I think it's gonna be
maybe oh that's that said more often
than not if you see me in a video where
I like I take a swig from a from of
alcohol it's I don't fake it cuz I'm too
lazy so like when I did the Jessica
Jones season 2 review I had like a
bottle of whiskey and I knocked it back
and that wasn't fake was it fake whiskey
Marvel has had a gay character in Alpha
Flight since the 90s yes they have
Marvel does OK in the comics so when I
say Marv on talking about the MCU
I'm not saying about the the comics
because I'm also Alpha Flight like is on
the docket to get us a movie so what did
you think of Shazam haven't seen it so
I'm assuming you missed the early part
of the the livestream
[Laughter]
all right so channel pop just asked
apart from the observable absorb all off
obviously who is your all-time favorite
Doctor Who villain now that's a double
layered joke because that's that's a
that's a Doctor Who joke in general but
for folks who don't know who channel pup
is he was he was the kid who created the
absorber lawful because the absorb off
in love and monsters was created by kid
and a contest and he now has a youtube
channel called channel pup and he's in
the chat and he's a cool dude
okay so setting aside the absorb all off
um well I'm gonna I'm gonna make the
choice to narrow it down to one time
villains since you made that comparison
and I would say the midnight entity can
I use sclera pronouns Futurama reference
I mean you can I'm not sure anyone else
is gonna know what you're talking about
have you listened to the Big Finish
Missy episodes I'd are those out
aye-aye-aye a Big Finish puts out so
much stuff like I I catch wind of what
is coming but I miss when it gets
released so if those are out I may need
to look into that and prioritize it
have you seen Robocop of 1987 of course
I have has anyone else thought that end
game might be Captain America's last
chance to get laid oh goodness yeah
actually if we if we're not gonna ship
captain Bucky which I have no problem
with but if we're not gonna do that it
is distinctly possible that cap is still
a virgin that's not a given but it's
possible
let's see I'm missing here I'd say the
most underrated sir and Doctor Who is
the unquiet dead or cold war I'm gonna
disagree because I really like either of
those that much
when does Hill to come out with new
episodes not till next year I don't
think favorite movies sequel probably
Dark Knight generic answer I'm sure but
original original Blade Runner is one of
my favorite movies of all time uh
Stuckey is all I need in life Cheers ah
lower your volume Polites
okay I missed a thing there have you
managed to listen to Hamilton nope
should cap wolf ever be brought to the
big screen as a primary story no as an
offhanded reference to a thing that
happened between movies yes with like I
would like a picture enough in a shield
folder that's how I want cap wolf do you
think the valley ardor the dream Lord
will ever come back in Doctor Who the
fat I don't care about the valley ardh I
really don't dream Lord I'd be down for
valiant I don't care your opinions on
assassin Creed's video games never play
them Clockwork Orange one of the few
Stanley Kubrick movies I actually enjoy
I mean I say enjoy it's in that sort of
twisted I'm a this makes me
uncomfortable kind of enjoyment but what
do you do most underrated Doctor Who
soundtrack assigns the library force the
dead that that has my personal favorite
track the Marigold ever did which is
greatest story never told oh I love that
track so much did you get a chance to do
any research on that we will rock you
musical and I mentioned last time I know
I have not had
the chance of the time or the
opportunity to look into it Meg
I will try and remember to do that but
it's like III feel bad cuz I get on the
live strings and I'm like I should look
into that and then the live stream ends
and I start doing other stuff and I
forget like I should actually I should
take notes from these things ah minority
opinion bill & ted's sequel is better I
don't know if it's better but it is
different enough that it definitely is
valid to judge it as its own entity
what is the absorber off kids channel
called again channel pop he's I unless
he left he's actually in the in the chat
here somewhere who do you think the
first live-action LGBT superhero in film
will be well for my money they're gonna
end up taking a character that is not
already lgbtq+ in the comics and have
them be that because you know that's
that's certainly something can do
they've made enough changes to various
other things from race to gender to you
know whatever to name to whatever else
with plenty of these characters so I
mean I think that might be part of again
assuming there wasn't an original source
on it that might be part of what is
feeding the the whole speculation on the
Eternals because since almost nobody
knows the Eternals those are the kind of
characters that they could take one and
make them an LGBT pew lgbtq+ character
and it's not gonna make that as big of a
deal as doing it with one of the bigger
ones
so I can't like I do not normally
associated with the Eternals I don't
think but I mean if they're gonna
rearrange it as much as they did with
Gardens dideoxy just drop moondragon in
there and there you go the thing you
know do you have rivers screwdriver not
only do I have River screwdriver haha
this
was the very first sonic screwdriver I
ever got so I'm quite fond of this ah oh
it's starting to buffer on people Oh
shame
how long have I been going oh it's about
time for me to Road to wrap up wrap up
anyways
oh it's buffering okay if anyone if
anyone is still able to hear me let them
know in the chat that it's time for me
to wrap it up anyways if anyone can hear
me at all god alright fun none if if I'm
not buffering for you could you let
everyone else know that I said it's time
for me to wrap it up anyways I feel bad
yeah so well thank you for uh for
sticking wood for sticking with me
and thanks for dropping in I I was I was
afraid when I started doing this that it
was gonna be like oh is this gonna start
to feel like an obligation am I still
gonna enjoy doing it I've been doing
this a couple of months now I think
still fun so thanks for that
hope everyone has a good night I hope
you have a good rest of your week and
[Music]